[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue Laurent sur
chescom pour cette première demi-finale
de la Process League
salut Stéphane salut à tous et oui
effectivement ça y est c'est toi qu'on a
commenté toute l'année souvent tous les
deux et bien ça y est ça touche à sa fin
malheureusement
on a vu hier que
est tombé contre les Indiens de Indian
yogi qu'on va voir maintenant face à
Shanghai Tiger bon beau match hein mais
moi ce que j'ai ce que j'ai senti c'est
que malheureusement l'équipe Blitz c'est
personne en forme personne en grande
forme voilà donc tout le monde
pas dans le dur non plus mais voilà
personne en grande forme et en général
c'est vrai qu'il faut un MVP quelqu'un
qui qui met des points à chaque ronde
pour pour gagner ce genre de match et en
face du solide les Indiens ils sont
quand même très très forts et on a une
grosse demi-finale clairement avec face
aux joueurs face aux Chinois on avait
dit c'est chinois on les trouvait
dangereux sans qualifiés facile ils sont
en demi-finale maintenant gros client
qu'est-ce que tu en penses bah écoute
c'est deux grosses équipes là ici alors
juste un tout petit truc parce que là
sur Manchester est même il me dit que
les gens sont pas en train de jouer et
ça devrait avoir commencé
d'accord et donc ouais ben Chine 1 c'est
un peu alors c'est qu'est-ce que c'est
cette project League en fait c'est des
clubs un petit peu virtuels qui
s'organise donc c'est le plus fort
championnat de club au monde online
voilà tout simplement où les joueurs on
voit de super puissants là des échecs
mondiaux entre les Indiens évidemment
qui produisent on a parlé avant une
chose
un nouveau grand maître par semaine on
exagère un petit peu mais et les Chinois
qui sont un peu finalement ce que je te
disais moi c'est je trouve que c'est en
perte de vitesse parce qu'il produisent
pas de nouveaux prodiges mais bon ils
ont les deux champions du monde donc ils
ont dit rien évidemment qu'il ne vous
champion du monde et Juventus qui va
jouer ici qui est la championne du monde
évidemment les Chinois qui sont bien
présents sur le chéquier mondial donc
voilà c'est très très beau match entre
deux superpuissances et ensuite mon cher
Stéphane on a le streamer américain
l'ogre l'ogre des États-Unis le grand
Nakamura et ouais à 18h30 la deuxième
demi-finale avec Gotham chess peut-être
les gothams sont les favoris de cette
compète
ils ont vraiment une très grosse équipe
on verra mais on suivra Hikaru et voilà
Hikaru qui peut faire la différence
quasiment
faire gagner des matchs à lui tout seul
donc
on va évidemment rappeler le format il y
a on joue contre les quatre joueurs de
l'équipe adverse donc il y a normalement
il y a 4 matchs 4 mm de 4 points donc
faut faire 8 et demi donc rendez-vous
compte si un joueur fait 4 sur 4
ça garantit pas la victoire évidemment
mais ça c'est la favorise clairement
donc là on va voir on a pragalanda pour
les Indiens ça doit Nick un jeune joueur
veille chez lui qui la sœur de Prague
très très dangereuse qui a fait beaucoup
de mal hier à nos à nos amis de Blitz et
Pradesh qui était en feu hier tu m'as
dit et c'est vrai que
il a fait un très bon match mais bon ces
joueurs ces joueurs chinois donc il y
avait I qui était un des meilleurs
prodiges qui est un peu en perte de
vitesse mais bon il joue pas trop en
fait c'est ça le problème c'est qu'il
peut pas trop sortir de Chine et donc
pas trop jouer
la championne du monde donc Souilly très
très gros clients et Louis ping qui est
peut-être le joueur plus faible de cette
équipe mais attention faut se méfier
faut se méfier de tous ces joueurs
chinois donc gros gros match on va voir
salut à tous dans le chat n'hésitez pas
on a alors on a un léger décalage d'une
minute Stéphane pour évidemment toujours
pareil
pas du tout
[Musique]
je vais essayer de notre manière et je
n'arrive pas plus
alors que l'inverse c'est mieux
je ne changer attends j'espère parce que
je voulais faire on va dire ça
je vais essayer de trouver en fait les
parties excusez-moi je j'ai un bug qui
fait que je n'arrive pas
vas-y je parle de cette belle peau de
chasing qui est quand même là la plus
belle compétition des clubs évidemment
il y a eu plein de choses qui sont
passées évidemment il y a eu un match
championnats du monde depuis la dernière
fois qu'on sait qu'on a fait un stream
Stéphane très très beau match avec
dingueren le nouveau champion du monde
et
il y a le tournoi en ce moment il y a un
tournoi qui empêchait malheureusement
Maxime machinagrave de participer à
l'équipe Blitz qui est forcément
handicapant de devoir se passer d'un
joueur de ce calibre
et c'est un peu dommage évidemment faut
être sûr d'avoir tous ces joueurs on
peut pas avoir tous ces joueurs tout le
temps dispo c'est ça le problème des
compétitions par équipe qui se déroule
sur l'année c'est compliqué
mais on va voir ça et on va voir le
jaune le jaune Prader lambda qui est
qui est déjà qui est déjà top 25 top 30
mondial toujours d'imaginer qu'il soit
pas un jour dans le top 10 mondial donc
très très gros clients
je pense qu'on a les le micro de Steph
est très bas la panne
peut-être que c'est trop qui est trop
élevé alors en fait parce que le mien il
a à côté de moi mon micro on a compris
64 510 j'adore les pseudos au truc
[Musique]
alors moi je me suis essayé Stéphane
depuis qu'on s'est pas vu il va arriver
plein de malheur toi aussi tu es arrivé
des malheurs avec cette nuit plein de
malheur à plein de choses à cette qualif
là
à cette calife j'ai fait j'ai pas été à
parier une ronde j'étais absent pendant
5 minutes et j'ai fait quand même j'ai
fait 5 et donc je suis qualifié à 72
premiers je veux mon petit match mais
c'est dommage parce que j'aurais pu et
je vais jouer pour être en Division 3
alors là j'ai une pièce de plus et j'ai
perdu non incroyable ah c'est une pièce
de plus en finale mais plus de temps
panique perdu énervement aussi de pas
avoir été à Paris alors on lui tu
imagines
c'est ballot et tu vois je pouvais jouer
une place pour division 2 même pas
division 2 quoi et
un peu en tilt sur ce truc là mais on se
rapproche on se rapproche de la calife
pour pour ces trucs là il y a la
cheesekid Cup qui aura lieu à la fin du
mois donc avec notamment le meilleur
d'entre nous qui est tu sais qui est en
Division 1 non le champion de France en
titre étant division 1 Jules Moussa
incroyable
mais non il a perdu son match
et donc il devait être en division 2 et
il se trouve que guéri et chefchakok
sont qualifiés ont refusé ils se sont
désités parce que ils ont le ils ont le
grand Chaft tour à en Pologne je crois
donc en fait c'est les types qui jouent
des califes qui se qualifient mais qui
disent non à la fin c'est incroyable en
fait non
qui sont lancés là je suis sur un autre
truc là je suis désolé on a je veux que
de partout j'ai que deux parties
j'ai que deux parties je vous mets ça
pour l'instant oui mais ça commence en
décaler oui mais en fait là c'est
vraiment trop décalé un genre Prague il
a déjà commencé et j'ai pas sa partie il
nous manque il nous manque des cases on
va être on va être mal ouais
moi j'avais réglé sur un autre format ah
oui c'était en mode c'était en mode
excuse-moi je vais revenir
j'ai un bug parce que là c'est même pas
du tout la bonne présentation si tu veux
normalement je vais être en mode théâtre
et là bah je sais pas moi tu as du tout
je peux pas même pas le faire parce que
je suis pas sûr
tu es en mode 80% des chèques mais bon
on va avoir les blancs sont bien après
d'après la jauge et blanc sont bien
on va voir je vais je vais vous regarder
ça pendant que de l'autre côté je vais
je vais magouiller un peu mais oui ça
[Musique]
ça bug pas mal ici
et on va voir cette première position oh
là là c'est pas un gars qui est blanc là
on est d'accord
du matériel en plus et une attaque c'est
terminé dans cette première partie mais
qui est-ce qui sont les gens
ça doit être contre
là entre le jeune ça doit ni quand on
devine là
oh là là quel pâté parce que là c'était
dame contre deux pièces plus attaque de
maths d'ailleurs je suis désolé
il fallait encore qu'on fasse quand même
bien les choses mais les
tables sont un peu inversées
et donc en fait
[Musique]
ça doit qui s'est fait éclater
et le temps même le temps vous le voyez
pas en fait parce que c'est pas le bon
format ah ça m'énerve
j'essaie de me connecter avec un autre
compte
Thomas on m'a filé un compte caché
le fait d'être pompier
[Musique]
de l'humour on aime quand c'est
bienveillant problème de budget chez
chascom il fournissent que 80% de
l'effectif ouais c'est ça c'est ça
quoi j'ai 7 tours G3 le roi de reculer
on fait un petit coup de dames d'un H6
là et roi 8 tours prend G8 échec et
c'est fini donc on a pas trop vu mais là
impressionnant
joueur chinois peut-être une prépa et
voyez un zéro ça s'affiche pour les
Chinois
moi je dis depuis le départ faut se
méfier des Chinois j'ai j'ai une très
mauvaise expérience avec une mauvaise
expérience et les Chinois je les ai vu
au Championnat du Monde par équipe là en
novembre dernier
je reconnaissais pas si j'en connais un
ou deux dans l'équipe ils ont ils ont
battu tout le monde assez facile
qui a beaucoup beaucoup de très très
bons joueurs en fait qui sortent pas
trop qui reste en Chine et qui sont très
sous-classés
et donc forcément très dangereux et là
j'ai l'impression que oui par exemple
c'est typique parce que ça doit ni
attention ça doit ni jouer à plus de
2006 hein en partie classique donc pas
un vous voyez il est jeune en plus donc
plutôt sur la pente ascendante
pas comme tout le monde et donc
voilà c'est quand même assez
impressionnant
cette première victoire à ma caméra
saute j'ai l'impression
[Musique]
cet écran parce que là je suis en train
de voir pour mettre l'autre
et salut à toi matelot merci de nous
rejoindre on va être mieux en place là
et puis
Nakamura qui arrive il y a déjà pour la
deuxième partie on sera un peu plus en
place
le code là j'attends malheureusement je
suis désolé hein ça prend un peu tout ça
de et demain demain on se retrouve pour
la grande finale 15h30 d'abord peut-être
match pour la troisième place et ensuite
la grande finale pour savoir qui gagne
cette ligue exceptionnelle où on
rappelle Fabien de Carona a participé
Magnus Carlsen l'ancien
l'ancien ça me fait ouf ça me fait mal
au coeur de dire ça mais l'ancien
champion du monde toujours champion du
monde de rapide et Blitz qu'un tube
champion du monde qui a pris il y a pas
d'effort du son titre et donc c'est des
nouveaux champs pour du monde même si
Magnus reste évidemment numéro 1 numéro
1 mondial
je t'ai vu la partie de prenais je
retrouve
en équipe sur Internet c'est
toujours comme ça enfin toujours comme
ça non
alors qu'est-ce qui se passe dans cette
karaoké
assez agressif
c'est très rapide pour ouvrir la colonel
et on voit cette dame qui est pas mal
positionnée les fous beaucoup de pièces
master aller droit pour les dames et
pour les dames pour les noirs
et donc des chances d'attaque sur le
long terme la case la case en E5 vous
voyez un trou en E5 qui est quand même
dur à
belle avant-poste pour les blancs donc
du long terme sur le long terme c'est
bien pour les blancs sur le court terme
ça peut être pas terrible
donc va falloir faire des choses très
concrètes avec les noirs
voir comment on fait il va se
débrouiller
qu'elle est H4 il doit prendre une
décision ou pas est-ce qu'il est urgent
de prendre une décision de roquet
peut-être j'en sais rien
je viens rester chez qui est là je viens
juste remettre ça sur
ce qui arrive
salut à toi renard 30 et bienvenue
monsieur qui est là maintenant il faut
que je le redimensionne parce que du
coup bah on revient sur des vrais sur
mais là ça y est ça y est en place ouais
mais en fait c'est mon compte
je sais pas c'est bizarre surtout je
peux rien follow par contre par contre
sur le compte chaise comme FR et ben
écoute
j'ai tout forcément
donc là
je t'embête encore une fois ou pas
et là on est on est vraiment au top
et c'est pas évident moi je vous le dis
bon allez on peut commencer je suis
désolé ce petit problème
mais enfin vraiment que je vois parce
que c'est pas la première fois que j'ai
un problème avec mon compte que j'arrive
pas à follow les parties quoi parce que
tu vois tout est en place le plus dur
c'était vraiment de mettre tout Obs en
place le plus simple c'est de cliquer
sur follow
mais juste ça marche pas quoi l'appareil
raisonnable voilà est-ce que le son il
est il est bon maintenant j'ai pas du
tout regardé le chat ce qu'on a réussi à
rééquilibrer un petit peu
tout ce qui tout ce qu'il fallait au
niveau du son
et il y a pas eu trop de plaintes quand
les gens se plaignent pas trop c'est
qu'ils sont pas trop mécontents
il a rocket position très riche donc
veillez si j'ai clairement la gagne dans
cette première partie
son jeu adversaire super joueur veillant
très sous-estimé
[Musique]
c'était quand c'était
c'était vendredi qu'il a je crois ou
jeudi je sais plus quel jour il a joué
jeudi je crois pas si tu as vu le match
contre notamment contre
pranave c'était juste cavalier étranger
deux
fois c'était c'était un truc de ouf et
on avait invité à l'époque Ding avec
Manu ça va éviter Ding et un stage
d'entraînement donc il y avait une
dizaine de jours et digne parler de
veilli si tu veux comme quelqu'un de
plus fort que lui de potentiellement
plus fort que lui je suis du Moral
chinois mais ça a pas duré il y avait
qui arrive il y avait meilleur que moi
très modeste et je pense qu'il disait ce
qu'il pensait bon aujourd'hui les
champion du monde pavéi c'est trempé
Ding tant mieux pour lui mais voilà il
était tu vois donc ça démontre Ding dit
ça ça démontre potentiel quand même
assez assez élevé et donc c'est pas
étonnant qu'il fasse des parties
fantastiques de temps en temps
[Musique]
je crois que c'est à 14 ans qu'il a
sorti je crois que c'était celui de
l'heure et ma mère
comme Magnus Carson il y avait une
trajectoire à la Magnus carcène quand
même
[Musique]
évidemment il y a le covid qui l'a
complètement mais même avant déjà ça
commençait sa carrière commencé à
ralentir
pourquoi
c'est toujours toujours compliqué on
sait
vraiment même parfois les joueurs le
savent pas simplement c'est pas évident
ces choses à régler sur pas évidentes
alors on a la paire de fou avec les
blancs mais les noirs sont pas mal on va
menacer peut-être fougères
pas mal sur casse blanche avec les
Blancs j'aime bien les blancs on voit
bien qu'il manque
6 bien joué pour empêcher justement
et maintenant comment on fait avec les
Blancs
on pourrait essayer d'ouvrir un peu la
position
qui va venir aussi à ouvrir un peu les
colonnes les diagonales pour pour un peu
tout le monde c'est prise qui avait
chacun qui pourrait arriver
très activement avec les Noirs donc
ouvrir la position ouais sur le concept
avec la paire de fou complètement
accordé mais faut pas oublier que c'est
toujours aussi concret de jeu et donc
c'est pas forcément sûr que ça soit une
bonne idée
peut-être qu'il est pas mal en fait avec
les Noirs bizarrement
[Musique]
à la française qui avait des cavaliers
des deux qui avaient laissé 6 la quand
ça se passe bien pour les Noirs dès que
tu arrives à jouer 5 j'ai l'impression
que
c'est une française sans le foot casse
blanche enfermée en fait tu es en train
de nous dire ouais donc c'est vrai que
c'est plus simple on va il y en a ils
préfèrent avoir tu sais il y a des
joueurs de françaises ils jouent la
française et ils adorent avoir leur faut
enfermer tu vois c'est c'est un autre
délire tu vois mais normalement il vaut
pas trop le faire donc et B3 clairement
là il veut il veut prendre 5 et jouer et
jouer cahier des quatre est-ce qu'il va
se prendre 4 je pense que 4 et le coup
très très candidats
cavalière 4 attention
voilà je vais te montrer une belle une
variante qui va te plaire sur G3 G3 je
te connais maintenant j'ai trois je fais
cavalier H4 je pense et carriage 3 si tu
prends H4 pour menacer pour ma tante je
fais pour montrer le potentiel des noirs
sur purpro H4 j'étais à Match 3 et c'est
terminé je crois
c'est un petit peu le même genre que
j'ai de la partie que je t'ai dit De
Wailly contre
entrepreneur je t'invite à la voir après
franchement assez monstrueux très bien
mais mais c'était pas mal hein et bon
c'est oui qui avait les Noirs donc là en
fait j'ai trois cavaliers H4 c'est
clairement
il y a pas de problème notre ami en face
de pays prend neige ça j'ai trois et
c'est pas évidemment qu'il va le voir
pour essayer d'ouvrir la colonne F et la
paire de fou je je te fais allez je te
fais carrer H4 vas-y moi je jouais eh
ben c'est bien tu prends de toi-même les
les blancs moi je préfère
très malin et H4 me semble assez tentant
fini
peut-être qu'il veut juste faire F4
et essayer de
bloquer ton fou et son cache blanche
alors vas-y vas-y on bouge les pièces
non on bouge pas
[Musique]
mais le Cavalaire en B3 fait rien du
tout complètement deviner
un autre résultat légalisation des
joueurs indiens avec peut-être celui que
je vous avais dans la présentation
Louis Pink est peut-être le maillon
faible chez chinois va falloir le viser
il me semble que c'est le c'est le plus
léger des joueurs chinois bon même si on
peut pas parler léger mais en tout cas
c'est le moins chevronné
des quatre joueurs chinois donc il va
falloir le visser le hipping parce que
sinon ça va être compliqué les autres
ont l'air quand même veilli j'ouvre le
jour de la champion du monde qu'on
présente plus et oxoui qui a Camille qui
a quand même mis d'un coup pour
commencer à s'adonner donc
gros client aussi
c'est la partie c'est parti
ok donc maintenant à mon avis le seul
coup c'est toi F2 et sur cavalier F5
sur kf5 Dame des deux qu'est-ce que
je peux continuer avec H5 et j'ai quatre
H5 comme ça je peux peut-être reprendre
du pion mais que j'ai quatre très très
bien ouais non on va les noirs sont
mieux les noirs sont tu t'es embarras du
choix
F4 qui va être un problème il y a aussi
des vis-à-vis sur le droit qui est
faible et au final comme c'est une
question fermée le cavalier ici a du mal
à bouger et des fous sont pas si bon que
ça vu que la position elle est vraiment
fermée là
et en plus les ruptures je pense qu'il y
a quand même plutôt chez les noirs
tous les voyants sont ouverts c'est
assez terrible en fait c'est assez
déprimant cette cette position et que
les Blancs le seul le seul truc
le seul élément
sur lequel on peut se réjouer avec les
Blancs à 6 mais un jour si on prend un 7
bon on voit pas de scénario on prend un
set mais si un jour on prend un set on
n'est pas marrant on n'est pas loin de
faire d'âme mais à part ça
alors
son utilité en finale notamment un type
pion raciste c'est ce que je disais
c'est que si tu si tu fais une course
par exemple te file mon aile roi et avec
mon roi par exemple je vais te prendre
une dame ça serait le seul scénario que
moi je pourrais voir le roi il va là-bas
je sais pas alors ouais non c'est pas un
scénario c'est crédible et bien je
prends à 7 et en plus les maintenant le
pion à 6 il est très proche de la case
de promotion donc c'est pour ça ça a été
montré un petit peu
on l'a vraiment compris ce truc là avec
l'arrivée de l'intelligence artificielle
notamment en 2017 avec avec cet alpha
zéro qui poussait le pion h et pion a
frénétiquement assez rapidement et c'est
vrai que c'est devenu déjà c'était un
truc qui était connu c'est devenu très
très à la mode même dans les premiers
coups de la partie
alors je sais plus comment ça s'appelle
moi est-ce que je l'ai vu mais ce petit
pion assis j'avais vu que ça s'appelait
un pion de passer de réserve
ah d'accord c'est pas un pion passé
encore
parce que ben j'ai le pion à 7 et comme
tu l'as dit si on fait la course et bien
une fois que j'ai mangé là-bas je suis
déjà en fait prêt à partir quoi
cette tour 1 ce qui est en B3 qui ont
pas du tout d'espace on a largement
assez de compensation pour la qualité
pense pas que veiller à tes seins en
fait peut-être remarque après ça reste
du
ça reste du
Blitz bon c'est du rapide Blitz à très
vite les gens peuvent rater des choses
mais ok
qui demande est-ce que est-ce confirmé
que veiller était secondaire à distance
de Ding pour le Championnat du Monde
moi j'ai rien lu en sens mais je suppose
qu'il avait de l'aide en Chine et il
s'entendent très bien en tout cas à
l'époque moi je sais la dernière fois
chez
le stage dont je parlais il s'entendait
très bien il s'entraîner ensemble donc
mais c'était 2015 donc c'était
ça date un petit peu mais ça serait pas
étonnant alors qui exactement évidemment
on a vu rapporte qui était tout le temps
avec lui je pense pas du monde
normalement c'est un peu léger pour un
match
c'était tellement attachant les dehors
ils ont eu une cote de popularité
incroyable
et c'est logique c'est logique parce que
tout simplement
ça doit ni pas sodomie pardon
on l'a mis Prades et c'est la dernière
partie
donc la petite sœur de Prague elle a
fait nul avec jouvenju très bon résultat
pour les Indiens un et demi partout
que je suis une nuit difficile
et que je je vais dire beaucoup de
bêtises aujourd'hui je pense donc faut
pas trop trop m'en vouloir si je fais
des erreurs de calcul
cavalier F6 a été joué ok je crois j'ai
tout raté en fait et c'est apparemment
une gaffe d'après la jauge j'aurais
peut-être pu prendre 3 il faut prendre
trois marches ça va pas j'ai
l'impression qu'il faut prendre pas mal
de comme ça
[Musique]
on a royal chef qui est arrivé
salut mon petit royaume mon petit mon
petit joueur de Bullet
donc je peux pas manger a priori aussi
tu fais quoi
et si je prends et
enfin je prends
H3 et qui joue qui prend les trois
ok ouais c'est chaud c'est très très
chaud
tout à fait une question bonjour j'ai
commencé les échecs si vous faites comme
haïku n'hésitez pas à venir poser vos
questions il y a environ deux mois et
bienvenue dans une grande famille on
fait les coups tu vas voir
tu vas voir si tu as du mal à t'en
passer après c'est compliqué après une
fois qu'on commence hein
de la drogue mais c'est c'est
addictif voilà c'est ça et c'est de la
bonne drogue voilà c'est de la bonne
drogue donc voilà parce que ça bouge
alors
et la bonne et la mauvaise drôle
ne faites pas ça j'aimerais progresser
vous conseiller de jouer un peu tous les
jours ou beaucoup sur deux jours alors
moi ce que je lui dirai tout je sais pas
si tu es d'accord avec moi c'est de
jouer un peu tous les jours pour garder
le plaisir la fraîcheur plutôt que de
jouer alors nous on a fait exprès on a
fait des nuits entières à faire des
Blitz mais c'est pas forcément là où on
apprend le plus c'est plus du tilt que
autre chose en fait je pense quand tu
joues faut faire ça un peu un peu
intelligemment parce que tu publies pour
buter quoi pour passer du temps mais
après c'est vraiment que tu amélioré
déjà ben le Blitz c'est pas forcément ce
qu'il faut parce que en plus tu joues
vite et pas forcément bien c'est juste
plutôt un plaisir on va dire
mais si tu progressé plus jouer des
parties rapides enfin dites rapides
c'est un peu plus
lentilles
pour pouvoir vraiment faire des bonnes
parties rien rater analyser les parties
etc donc c'est mieux de jouer comme ça
et pas tous les jours enfin il y a pas
s'abrutir à faire 10 heures par jour
quoi parce que tu vas finir par être
dégoûter ça va te saouler et c'est
tester c'est comme quand tu aimes bien
une chanson tu vas l'écouter non-stop
pendant une semaine après tu veux plus
écouter quoi après c'est fini quoi tu
vois donc il faut il faut doser quand
même sinon
ça part vite quoi c'est ce que je pense
après bon je pense chacun est différent
encore une fois
évidemment évidemment si je peux ouais
par exemple
et il couche je peux te dire que Magnus
Carlson il fait très attention s'il est
pas en forme il joue pas même des
parties amicales il fait très très
attention à ça rien que pour la
confiance parce que tu sais si tu perds
prendre 10 bulles consécutives et bien
c'est bon pour la confiance de personnes
donc faut faire attention aussi et je
sais que Magnus il fait très très
attention même dans des parties dites
amicales ou d'entraînement il joue pas
si un jour il se sent pas en forme mais
je joue pas
voilà donc il pense que c'est une bonne
c'est une bonne manière de faire les
choses il faut le il faut le sentir et
regarde ah la la vie il est un peu
écœuré là mais on le comprend on le
comprend qu'il soit écœuré et regarde ce
pion on va parler de racisme mais ce qui
va peut-être faire la différence au
final il faut aller le prendre
C8 ça gagne il peut la gagner il va
réfléchir
assis qui va faire la différence le pion
presque passé
on voyait pas de scénario le plus à cet
été perdu mais voyez on l'a vu ce
scénario et donc souvent et abandon soit
on dit que cavalier fou et ben c'est
meilleur qu'une tour et ben en fait il y
a des scénarios où la tour elle est
meilleure que les cavaliers enfin que
les deux pièces c'est ben quand on est
en finale que la tour elle est active et
on peut manger plein de pions et aussi
quand j'ai un pion passé comme ça donc
là c'est clair que c'est c'est très bien
joué un de la part de pranes qui qui a
battu Wayi donc
de l'équipe chinoise donc 2 1 2 et demi
1 et demi pour pour l'équipe des Indiens
quand même de notre ami pranes
c'est des parties rapides donc tout peut
se passer enfin tout peut se passer en
tout cas il faut se battre jusqu'au bout
parce que 10 + 2 vous voyez il peut
quand même avoir des retournements de
situation quand il y a moins de temps
même pour un joueur du calife de VI et
on a dit beaucoup de bien je pense à
juste titre qu'en joueur les meilleurs
joueurs mondiaux
pays champion olympiques avec les
Chinois donc
il connaît la pression en plus
on va voir c'est intéressant en tout cas
les Indiens qui mènent deux nuits
je sais pas
on va voir
ça dépend un peu j'ai l'impression que
si Louis pink prend l'eau aujourd'hui
je crois qu'ils vont faire des Chinois
il se prend s'il fait moins de 1 point
ils ont perdu parce que
ça va être dur de tout gagner à côté
et il peut vraiment faire très peu de
points je pense que
on va voir la ronde 2 va commencer
bientôt
je suppose être une petite pause pour
laisser souffler les joueurs
en général ça reprend vite
et on va avoir donc les appareils de la
ça se bug tout seul les appareils de la
deuxième partie
[Musique]
pour l'instant
je le place pour gagner un petit peu de
temps
pour avoir donc on rappelle le joueur
numéro 1 de l'équipe d'une équipe joue
le 4 de l'équipe adverse
ensuite on a le on a le deux qu'on a le
troisième de l'équipe adverse et
inversement pour l'autre équipe donc à
la fin on termine par des par des matchs
entre eux numéro 1 numéro 2 au même
numéro donc plus ça va plus c'est
équilibré c'est ça l'idée en plus il y a
de tension et plus de choses possible
on va voir si on va peut-être rentrer
dans ce match on sait pas ça menace
d'être serré j'imagine pas un match
passé
les Chinois franchement je trouve très
impressionnant tous les deux
il faisait il faisait pas mal de points
mais il semble que c'était quand même
dans les autres matchs je sais pas il y
aura souvent mais bon ils ont une
féminine tellement forte joint
on rappelle c'est obligatoire il faut au
moins une femme dans les quatre joueurs
c'est bien
ça permet de valoriser
les femmes et donc il faut
évidemment le but du jeu étant à voir
entre guillemets comme pour les hommes
le meilleur rapport hello
helloforce voilà de faire son équipe en
fonction du classement et le checker il
y a une moyenne et l'eau à pas dépasser
et donc c'est un jeu habile
et donc parfois c'est vrai que si on a
une forte comme jouvaine jaune on est
obligé d'avoir un joueur un peu moins
fort comme le hipping c'est un peu le
défaut de l'équipe chinoise mais c'est
pas possible d'avoir quatre joueurs de
premier plan
ouais il faut faire de la tactique
n'hésite pas à faire des puzzles rush
sur James com
et très important la tactique et comme
ça que même même à nos niveaux
ça se joue souvent
sur
une combinaison les parties se terminent
comme ça
tu vas si tu fais des progrès puzzle
rush tu vas monter en flash sur le
c'est certain
on n'hésite pas
et même là tu peux t'entraîner tu vois
quand on commence
peut regarder c'est de calculer des
choses se mettre dans les conditions
d'une partie
allez je vais faire un petit coucou sur
sur Youtube est-ce que c'est est-ce que
ça bouge sur YouTube
ah je l'ai pas vu le chien
je vais lancer YouTube
il est pas comme ça
[Musique]
donc voilà
est-ce qu'on est sur Youtube ou pas
est-ce que quelqu'un voit moi je vois
pas sur YouTube
on est sur Magnus persan titre de
champion du monde aujourd'hui
ah oui
tous les jours
allez bon en tout cas elle est partie
vont commencer dans un instant on va
avoir on va avoir à la caméra
Prague contre
confiance